let's play the following game you throw
a dice
and if you get to six the game ends
otherwise
if you get any other number for example
here a five
you throw another dice and if you get a
six the game ends
otherwise you throw another dice and so
on until you get that six
that's it that's the whole game i never
said this was the most exciting game
so let's make it a bit more exciting
let's say that
every time that you get to throw a dice
you get paid
one dollar now the question is
how much in expectation would you make
playing this game
if you play again and again a large
number of games
how much would you make on average
another way of asking the same question
is how many throws of the dice does it
take
on average to get a 6.
we will offer three solutions to this
problem ranging from the
most straightforward and computational
to the most elegant
if you'd like you can pause the video
here and see what solutions
you can come up with
[Music]
let us denote by t the number of throws
that it takes to get the first six
and note that t is a random variable so
it would vary from one game to another
and what we're interested in is the
expectation of t
so before we derive this expectation
let's actually compute the distribution
of the random variable t so t
takes positive integer values only so
let's compute the probability that t
equals k
for every positive integer k
the probability of t equals 1 is 1 over
6
assuming the dice is fair this is
because there are
six possible outcomes and they are all
equally likely
easy enough what is probability that
t equals 2 well we need the first row
to be anything but a six which happens
with probability
five over six and the second row to b
is x which happens with probability one
over six
how about the probability that t equals
three now we need the first row
not to be six the second throw not to be
a six
and the third one to be a sx in other
words this
probability is given by five over six
squared times one over six
more generally the probability that
t equals k is given by 5 over 6
to the k minus 1 times 1 over 6.
now in order to compute the expectation
of t
what we need to do is multiply each
probability
with its respective value and take the
sum
replacing the probabilities with their
corresponding values
our job now is to evaluate an infinite
sum
i have warned you that this solution is
the most computational
and now we see why anyway we have come
this far
and we're not going to stop so close to
the goal
the first thing i'm going to do now is
pull the 1 over 6
out of the sum since it is a constant
next i'm going to use a neat little
formula
known as the infinite geometric series
we will take derivatives of
both sides of this identity
the derivative of the right hand side is
1 over
1 minus x squared and for the left-hand
side
we're going to take the derivative term
by term
and we're gonna use the fact that the
derivative of x to the k
is given by k x to the k minus one
we multiply the left hand side and right
hand side by 1 minus x
and finally we replace x with 5 over 6
and lo and behold the left hand side is
exactly
the formula that we found for the
expectation of t
and the right hand side simply evaluates
to six
the answer turns out to be surprisingly
clean despite the fact that the formulas
we used were kind of messy
you might wonder if there is a better
way to go about this problem
and indeed there is one and that's what
we will do next
before we do that though we make few
observations
incidentally the answer happens to be
six
which is the face of the dice we were
looking for
this is easily seen to be just a
coincidence though
since the answer wouldn't change if the
game had stopped after say
a four rather than a six
the sex actually comes from the fact
that the probability of getting
any number from a fair dice is one over
six
and more generally if an event has
probability p of happening
we expect that it would take one of
repeat tries
before the event happens for the first
time
for example it would take two coin flips
on
average to get the first head since the
probability of getting a head
or a tail is one half
let's now move on to the second solution
this solution relies on a clever
recursion the basic idea is that
when you throw a dice two things can
happen
with probability one over six you get a
six in which case the game ends right
away
otherwise with probability five over six
you get some other number and basically
you have just wasted the throw
and you have to start all over again
hence the recursion
if we entangle this diagram we get this
repeating or
recursive structure
the left child note is always similar to
the full tree
and it becomes clear from here that the
expected number of throws
after the first row is one over six
times zero plus five over six
times expectation of two
solving this equation directly leads to
expectation of t
equals 6 which is nice an
unexpected consequence of this way of
solving the problem is that
we recover the value of the infinite sum
of k times x to the k minus 1
in a completely different way than we
did before
without resorting to any derivation
tricks
for the third and most elegant solution
we will use
one of the most profound and yet
strikingly simple results in probability
theory
the law of large numbers the law of
large numbers
simply states that as you repeat a
random experiment
a large number of times the outcome will
converge to the
theoretical expected value for example
if you flip a coin once you can get
either a head or a tail
and it would be impossible to tell which
one you would get in advance
but if you flip 100 coins you can
predict with
some confidence that about half of the
flips would be heads
and the other half would be tails and
your confidence
would grow as the number of flips
increases
back to the problem we will now think a
little differently than we did
for the other two solutions in fact we
will imagine a scenario where
you don't play a single game but a large
number of games
i said a large number of games
much better and we will see in a second
why that's useful
and let's put all the throws next to
each other so that we have
a long sequence of throws
now notice that every game has to end
with a six
so the total number of games is equal to
the number of sixes
how many sixes are there in this
sequence we can use the law of large
numbers to estimate the number of sixes
to be
one-sixth of the total number of throws
we can also appeal to a simple symmetry
argument since
throwing a dice leads to 6 possible
outcomes
that are equally likely so we expect
each one of them
to appear 1 6 of the time the number of
throws itself
if we play 100 games is going to be 100
times the expected length of a single
game
after simplification we now have that
expectation of t
is approximated by 6. note that up to
this point we only have an approximation
and not an equality but this
approximation gets
better and better as the number of games
increases
and in fact becomes exact as this number
goes to infinity
but since the approximation itself does
not depend on the number of throws
then we actually have an equality here
this is one of those times
where it feels like we are strengthening
a result for free
meaning we go from an approximation to
an equality
without any extra effort and this is
thanks to the
law of large numbers if you want to
check your understanding of the
three solutions presented here try to
answer the following questions
what is the median number of throws
required
to get the first six
how many throws does it take not to get
one six but two sixes in a row
how many throws does it take to get a
six conditioned on the fact that all the
throws
so far were even
[Music]
you